the moment many of us have been waiting
for has finally
happened parallel 16 has been updated
with full support
for apple's m1 max resulting in much
better performance running the armed
version of windows 10
as i'm gonna show you guys in this video
with some benchmarks and
gaming footage and the best part is that
it's actually pretty quick and simple to
get it installed on your m1 mac
in fact i actually think it's even
quicker than installing bootcamp on
intel base max
so i've got to be honest the future for
apple silicon max is looking
very bright now before i get into the
improved performance of parallels
16.5 and windows 10 as you can see right
here
got my mouse connected windows 10 swipe
i'm in mac
that's amazing parallels is so good
before we get into that let me first
show you how to set the entire thing up
step by step so you can get it running
on your m1 mac
first of all you'll need to download the
latest version of parallels
by going to their website and simply
clicking download now
they do offer a full 14 day free trial
so i would go with that option to try it
out
and it should start downloading
automatically once finished open the dmg
file within your downloads folder
and then double click on the icon that
pops up to begin
then go through the next couple of
prompts and once it's finished
installing
accept the license agreement and give
parallels access to the folders that it
needs
to properly run it's going to let you
know that your mac has an m1 chip so
click
continue and at this point we're going
to need to get the windows
vhdx file head to google and type in
windows insider program
click on the first result and then click
on the register button
in order to do that you're gonna have to
sign into your account
so go ahead and do that now when you're
logged in you'll be sent to this page
and as you can see
i've already registered so instead
you'll see a register button
and there are just a couple of prompts
and agreements to go through and then
it'll let you know
that you've joined head to google again
and type in windows 10
on arm insider preview then click the
first result
and then right here you'll be able to
download the vhdx file that we need
which is a pretty large 9.1 gigabytes
once it's finished just drag and drop it
onto the center of the installation page
and then click continue i then chose the
games only option
since that's what i'll be using it for
and i also check the customize settings
box as well before clicking
create after a while the settings will
then pop up and as you can see in the
cpu and memory settings
the default is set to 4 cpu cores and 4
gigs of ram
now if you have the 16 gigabyte m1 mac
model
which i definitely recommend getting
then you can set it to 8 gigabytes or
even 12 if you'd like to
and then once you're finished with that
hit continue go through the rest of the
prompts
and then after just a bit the
installation will be complete
at that point you'll need to either log
in or create an account
then accept the agreements and then
you'll be completely finished
at this point i went ahead and i
downloaded steam and battle.net
from the web to get ready to download
some games now i've got to say that the
main benefit of parallels is that you
can easily swap
between mac os and windows by pressing
command
plus tab on your keyboard or swiping
with three fingers
on your trackpad you can also pause your
virtual machine by switching to mac os
then clicking on the parallels icon in
the menu bar clicking on actions
and then pause virtual machine now when
you swipe back to windows
you can see that it's paused and it's
not taking up any additional resources
and then to unpause simply click on it
and you're ready to go
and then if you ever want to shut it
down completely just shut it down using
the windows button in the bottom left
corner
like you usually would on your pc and
there you guys go
that was the full guide on how to
install windows 10
on an m1 mac using parallels and now
let's get into the fun part the
benchmarks and the gaming tests
as you guys can see i have geekbench 5
open right here
and you'll notice that it says 6
processors 6 cores
that's because i actually went into the
settings and i adjusted it and set it to
six cores and
six gigs of ram and testing it out it
actually works pretty fine so i went
with that
so we've got all this right here it does
not let you do the graphics test for
some reason because i guess it can't
detect it
because it's integrated and unified but
let's run the cpu benchmark now while
this is running i do
want to strongly recommend getting 16
gigs of ram
if you're going to be running parallels
or playing games
you really want 16. all right we have
our score and
this is absolutely insane i cannot
believe that the new version is running
this well when they say native they
really
mean native we're getting a single core
score of 1541
and 56.82 for multicore that is
incredible because this is an eight gig
machine
running through a virtual machine
now look at this score and compare it to
what you would get
on mac os and the difference actually
isn't that
big but here's the incredible part check
out the score of the latest
dell xps 13 with literally the best
intel laptop chip that they have right
now
this virtual machine is beating
the best intel laptop chip i cannot
believe that this is happening but wait
it gets even better because that dell
was running while plugged in check out
what happens
when you unplug it and run it on battery
power
yes the performance goes way
way down it is just kind of hilarious
and a little bit sad at this point that
the m1 is running through a virtual
machine and it's killing
the dell that's natively running x86
so yeah who knew that we would be
getting performance like this
only a few months after the m1 mac came
out with a brand new cpu architecture
that's just crazy and now let's finally
get into the gaming and while we did
have some success
we had a couple of failures i downloaded
battle.net the launcher
and i tried to play overwatch i tried to
play cold war
i tried to play warcraft 3 and none of
them would even
launch so that is a massive bummer
because i really like those games
but it seems like that's an issue with
the battle.net launcher
and there's some kind of bug that just
won't let the games run so
that really sucks now someone did
suggest to download a couple of extra
windows files
specifically the directx end user
runtime
by going to this page and also the x64
version of visual c
plus plus but unfortunately that didn't
help for those games either
in fact most games that use an
anti-cheat system for online multiplayer
will
not work either so that really really
sucks
but we do expect those systems to get
updated to allow
armbase chips sometime in the future
since
cs go currently works perfectly fine on
m1 max and that also has
an anti-cheat system but thankfully a
couple of games on steam
did work and here you go you guys can
see that we have final fantasy vii
final fantasy 10 and grand theft auto 5
all installed and they all work so let's
start out with final fantasy because
that's
very nostalgic and as you know it does
not work on mac
it's not supported on mac os so the only
way to play it is to run it through
windows 10
and it works so let's play it alright
guys look at it it's working
nostalgic so no glitches no issues
limit braver let's go over here in the
corner it looks like we're locked to a
nice
15 fps perfect
now i'm pretty sure this game actually
runs probably like something like i
don't know
something like that there you go
he's dead look at that guys that was fun
[Music]
and now let's get into final fantasy 10
right here watch this
even more nostalgic music
right here nice all right we're here in
the settings we got 1440 by 900 that's
the highest i can go because it's
probably like basic native but
everything else i turn
up as high as possible so there you guys
go
30 fps no glitching no nothing it's
very interesting because the last time
that i did this i tried to play this
game and i was getting a lot of
glitching for some reason
but now no issues
great yeah i got it there you go
boom anyway it seems like i haven't
played this in a while i'm about to lose
but
yeah everything's working perfectly fine
so now let's go ahead and move on
to grand theft auto 5. now i did
initially have some issues running grand
theft auto 5 but i went
online and i downloaded the rockstar
social games club
launcher separately and then after that
i was able to log
in and get it to run properly
everything's working it's definitely not
perfect
it's not the best fps unfortunately the
counter is not working but
we're getting playable performance now
this is impressive
because let me remind you this is
running through a virtual machine
and then on top of that windows within
that virtual machine
is emulating x86
and on top of that this is a base model
with eight gigs
of ram and it's only giving six
to the virtual machine this is just
insane and look at this it's not perfect
but
graphics actually do look pretty good
but let me show you the settings
if i go over to the graphics you can see
that i'm playing at 1920x1200 resolution
that's higher than 1080p 60 hertz
and let me remind you set your vsync to
half
that's the best performance that i'm
able to get by using that otherwise you
get a lot of glitchiness so
make sure that is on if you were to play
this on a 13 inch
intel macbook pro base model
it would probably do worse than this
because the intel integrated graphics is
horrible and the best part swipe
you're back on mac os thanks to
parallels
it's amazing dude what are you doing i'm
sorry dude i don't mean to like
sorry bro what are you doing oh what but
yeah
there you guys go that is how to get
windows 10 running
probably with the best performance out
of any other method with the new
parallel 16.5
update and looking at that geekbench
performance that we got
being better than the best intel laptop
chip
that is just incredible and i am so
impressed and excited for more software
to start supporting arm and m1 and apple
silicon chips
the future is going to look amazing
especially when we get those
m1x macbook pros or potentially
the imac next week which i really really
think is gonna happen so
yeah hopefully you guys enjoyed this
video and if you did go ahead
and tap the like button and click the
circle about to subscribe for more
videos like this one
check out one of those two right there
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]